so what's going on with the babylon 5
reboot and will it appear on our tv
screens much sooner than we expected
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
so back in september it was announced
that babylon five would be returning to
our tv screens show creator j michael
schninsky who i'm going to call jms from
now on because that's a very difficult
name to say
um and that's on twitter that he has
written the pilot
that he has a really good idea where the
show is going to go over the course of a
series and that it has been green lit
that he will be making the pilot
now
since then he's been on twitter several
times he's talked about how this show
might actually be on our screens much
sooner than we expected
he was asked will it be on our tv
screens in 2023 and his answer was no
actually
i'm planning to start filming in spring
of 2022 of the pilot
if i haven't screwed that up i'm going
to be able to start filming the
full-blown series in july june or july
sort of 2022 for a premiere on the cw
network by 4 2022 so we could actually
see the babylon 5 reboot
appear on our screens within the next 12
months
that for me is an incredible turnaround
but actually a very possible turnaround
and really you know what these tv series
back in the day traditional tv series
like we used to get not stream and tv
series that we get nowadays they do have
a 12-month turnaround from writing to
appearing on our screens because
obviously then the next series is
starting a production so they create a
series every 12 months
getting this series on our tv screens
within 12 months seems more than likely
and i'm very very excited by that
because it really shows a passion to get
this back on and a commitment from the
cw
so what can we expect from the new
series because he has hinted at a few
storylines that i'll talk about in a
second but first of all
the cw network is going to be appearing
on this for me is a network that creates
tv shows like the arrowverse you know um
the flash series and all these things
superman versus lowest at the moment and
superman versus lowe's like they're in a
fight well they are married but um
superman and lois um back in the day um
smallville they always have reasonable
production value and decent budgets
without you know maybe being massive
um but they do produce some really
interesting and sometimes very brave
television i'm thinking like the series
i zombie very clever tv show very not
really normal for a kind of a network
television show um but very brave very
creative this is a tv network that i
think will allow jms to have the
show that he wants to do and obviously
jms has had a very successful career
including babylon 5 and since
he has enough gravitas and enough
respect within the cw network that i
think they're going to let him do what
he wants without having too much
interference we're going to actually see
the babylon 5 jms envisages on our
screens
but how about the tv show itself now he
has obviously said this is going to be a
bottom up hard reboot it's not going to
be the babylon 5 group grew up with but
i think at its core there will be
certain parts that will be for example
the babylon 5 station still seems to be
a 5 mile long beacon in space space
station in the neutral zone with several
different species coming and going a
haven for smugglers and traffic and
explorers and everything else so that
will still be very much i imagine
similar or at least
something that we can recognize
but the tv show itself is going to be
very different he talks about how
babylon 5 reflected the culture and the
problems society back in the 90s and he
wants the new tv show to do exactly the
same but time has moved on we're talking
nearly 30 years
we do still have fractions in our
society we have friction within our
political systems we have a very diverse
society in a very fractured society he
wants the new bible babylon 5 to still
reflect that so we're still going to be
talking about some of the things like
freedom and things like that that we see
in babylon 5 from the original but in a
very different way
he's also though hinted what the
storyline is going to roughly be in the
new first series it's going to be still
based around captain sheridan bruce
broxlander's character from the first
series
he's going to be coming to the station
as its new captain
he is going to have some sort of
mysterious background which he kind of
hinted at in the first series as well
but i think this is going to go far more
into it
but as he arrives a earth company
accidentally triggers a conflict with a
species that they know very little about
and that might be anything up to a
million years ahead of them in
technology this is going to put babylon
5 at the front line of this conflict and
basically mean that they are the best
line of defense for earth's survival
who this enemy is going to be this is
not 100 clear because obviously we have
the conflict between the mimbari and
earth and the sheridan character was
right in the middle of that conflict
is we got are we going to see a repeat
of that or is that going to be something
that is sidelined because the conflict
with the shadows is going to be maybe
developed in a slightly different way
now this was always a species that sort
of had come from ancient times and had
been awoken to return to scourge through
the galaxy is this something that is
going to be maybe woken by earth
interference something that this earth
company does that triggers the conflict
or are we going to see the mumbari war
but in far more detail than we ever did
in the series and potentially delivered
a different way
either way i'm absolutely certain jms is
going to do a stunning job and this is
the one series in 2022 i'm most excited
about amazon can spend a billion quid on
lord of the rings
i'll take it or leave it
but babylon 5 returning to our screens
now that is something i am genuinely
excited about and i'm absolutely
convinced we're going to see lots of
twists and turns just like that in a
completely new series with a completely
new look
i can't wait i'm really excited
so if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification share it wherever you like
do all that stuff um go on facebook
we're on there there's a link in the
description we're also on twitter
there's a link there too
please guys tell me what you think in
the comments about the return of babylon
5 what sort of series would you like to
see what stories would you like to see
tackled are we afraid that this series
might get ruined like so many others and
become some woke nonsense
i very much doubt that though i don't
think jms would allow that nonsense to
go on but you know it's always a risk
so tell me what you think please i can't
wait to read your comments
as always please stay safe and i'll see
you next time